guys it happened again classified
military documents leaked on a game's
forums and you know which game we're
talking about Good Old War Thunder
shocking this time around someone posted
restricted documents of the ah-64d
Apache Longbow Attack Helicopters who
needs a helicopter that and for those
keeping count this was the third time
this happened in September alone too
much in an interview with Eurogamer the
Studio's head of PR as said that this
has happened at least 12 other times on
the game's forums all the pursuit of
Buffs and Nerfs or Thunder's Wikipedia
page even has an entire section
dedicated to the leaks Real Talk where
are y'all getting these documents
wouldn't you like to know weather boy